all right so if you guys watch my video
from yesterday which broke down
apple's one and a half hour long
developer video
you'll know that apple mentioned gaming
on their apple silicon max
many many times so we know that apple is
obviously making a big push for gaming
this year so in this video i want to
respond
to talos of tech in his viewpoint that
gaming isn't going to change
on apple silicon max and i'll explain
why i think
it's actually the opposite now i watched
taylor's of tech's response to my apple
silicon video
on his twitch live stream and first of
all
i want to say that i respect his stance
and his opinion
and i want to thank him for being humble
and respectful
and by the way go and check out his
channel because he makes some very
awesome videos
his viewpoint is that even though apple
is now finally making their metal
graphics tools available on windows
and even though iphone and ipad games
are coming to the mac
it's still not enough to encourage aaa
game developers
to start bringing actually great games
to the mac
his main point is that the gaming market
on the mac is currently not big enough
to make it worth it for developers
which i actually agree with at least
right now
that's why we don't have very many great
games on the mac
and that's the same reason why rocket
league for the mac was cancelled
so now let me explain my viewpoint on
why i think apple silicon
is gonna revive gaming on the mac it's
obvious that this year
apple is putting a huge focus on gaming
so i'll quickly list all of the main
changes
for the first time ever apple is giving
us full-fledged controller support
for third-party controllers across all
of their platforms
including supporting every single button
even
the rear triggers on the xbox
controllers and
the light bar and the touchpad on the
ps4 controller
the ipad is finally getting keyboard and
mouse gaming support for the first time
ever which includes the ability to lock
the pointer
for full screen games apple silicon macs
are going to be able to run
completely unmodified iphone and ipad
apps and games as is on day one
which is huge and they're already
automatically translating touch-based
controls on an iphone
to act as a mouse pointer click drag and
even zoom
and for more complex games since the
ipad is getting keyboard and mouse
gaming support
apple silicon max will instantly get
that functionality as well
for the games that adopt it or of course
they can use a gaming controller instead
apple also completely revamped their
game center
which now supports cross-platform online
multiplayer gaming across the apple tv
the iphone the ipad and the mac
apple is now allowing the resolution and
ui of landscape
iphone and ipad apps to be automatically
resized
to match the native resolution of macs
so 16x9 for the imac
and 16x10 for the macbook and apple is
completely changing up their swift ui
metal apis and coding so that developers
have to do as little work as possible
to support all of apple's platforms and
they're going to continue working on
this every year
with each wwdc event so basically
apple is setting the groundwork or the
foundation
so that if a game developer decides to
bring their game to the mac
it's going to be easier than ever before
it's gonna have much better controller
input support
and it's gonna take less work to
actually maintain the game
now that's where we reach the problem
which is taylor's of tech's
main point how will this encourage game
developers
to actually start bringing their games
to the mac
well first of all the main goal that
game developers have
is to make money and whether this upsets
all of you guys or not
over the past few years mobile gaming
has been quickly taking over the gaming
market
while pc and console gaming has been
slowly going down
and this trend is expected to continue
so realistically
in the long term if game developers want
to make as much money as possible
they eventually need to bring their
games to mobile devices
and that's why we've recently started to
see aaa game developers
transition to mobile gaming here's a
quick list of some of those games
epic games and fortnite pubg mobile
blizzard's heartstone activision's call
of duty mobile
riot games and league of legends wild
rift apex legends mobile
and blizzard's diablo immortal these are
some of the very first
aaa game developers bringing their games
to mobile
because that's where the money's at in
the future and apple silk and max are
going to be able to run
all of those games now i will agree and
admit that the current
x86 aaa windows games that you currently
love to play on your pc
are not gonna come to the mac unless the
developer decides to port it over
but here's why i think aaa games are
gonna make it to the mac
because apple silicon chips in the
iphone and the ipad have been getting so
powerful in recent years
in fact even supporting ray tracing this
shows us that the apple silicon max are
gonna be
even more powerful and based on the
calculations that i made in a previous
video
apple silicon max have a ton of
potential
so within a couple of years of chip
improvements like tsmc's three nanometer
process coming to apple devices
in 2022 the performance will be so good
that game developers will realize that
they can build
much better games for these chips than
ever before and since the mobile gaming
market
is taking over pc gaming with each
passing year more and more
aaa game developers will start creating
better and better mobile games
which will eventually become the aaa
games of the future
that will run on arm-based max and
arm-based pcs
many years down the road and since those
games for the mac will use the same code
base
as on the ipad the iphone and the apple
tv
the developer doesn't have to optimize
and fix bugs
for the various platforms separately
this was the reason why minecraft for
the apple tv was cancelled
and why rocket league on mac was also
cancelled
the developers had to invest a lot of
extra time and money
into maintaining those games for those
platforms
which they won't have to do in the
future so basically this is how i can
imagine triple a games on apple silicon
max
playing out in the future a game
developer will first create a game with
very high quality graphics for the mac
and then make minor and relatively easy
adjustments
like lowering the graphics quality
presets the resolution
and adjusting the ui for every other
apple platform
like the apple tv the ipad and the
iphone
and that way their game supports all
apple devices
while only having to do the bulk of the
code work
one time for the mac so they're reaching
the maximum amount of the apple gaming
market
so if a game developer ultimately wants
to create a game
for the iphone they can first do their
code work as if
it's for the mac and reach all of
apple's platforms
at once instead of just the iphone which
is definitely worth
the work of adjusting the ui and the
resolution across different platforms
and the beauty of it is that when
there's a bug that needs fixing
or code optimizations that need to be
done the developer only has to do it
once since the main code is shared
across the iphone
the ipad the apple tv and the mac this
alone will make it worth it for
developers to bring their games over to
apple silicon max
and since apple now supports universal
purchase across all of their platforms
you can buy the game just once and have
access to it across all of your apple
devices
so a player can play that game on their
apple tv on the big screen
or on their macbook at a coffee shop or
on their ipad on the couch or on their
iphone
while on the bus and their progress is
automatically saved
across all of the platforms and that
person playing on their mac
will get online multiplayer crossplay
support
so they can game with players using any
apple device platform
depending on the input controller device
that he's using
now of course all of this is not gonna
happen overnight
it may take a few years to see this kind
of gaming
fully implemented but what i can tell
you is that this is definitely going to
begin
when apple silicon max start making it
to the market later this year
and game developers realize that they
can kill
four platforms with one code by building
their game for the mac first
and it'll definitely start to begin when
activision blizzard
and other game studios announce how much
revenue
their new mobile games have already
brought in
like the current call of duty mobile and
future games like diablo immortal
and league of legends wild rift and the
even bigger point is that if these
initial changes to gaming that apple
made to their platforms
at this year's wwdc already make
all of the things that i mentioned in
this video possible
imagine what apple is going to announce
at future wwdc events over the next
couple of years
that'll make it even easier and more
worth it for developers
to bring their games to the mac so based
on all of that
i'm extremely confident that apple
silicon is gonna
improve the gaming situation for the mac
since it'll support where the future
gaming market is currently headed
which is gaming on arm architecture
based chips
and this transition will be sped up
significantly
if over the next couple of years apple
silicon turns out to be much more
powerful than we're expecting
which may in turn cause the next version
of windows
to support both x86 and arm-based chips
and maybe in a couple of years intel
will have no other choice than to start
investing more
into making arm-based chips however i do
want to agree with talos of tech on
one point that the current x86 windows
games
that are available on pcs right now
probably
won't be making it to the mac and for
that i actually have a really great
solution
for that problem so if you want to know
how that's going to be possible
click that subscribe button above right
now so you don't miss out on my next
video
and definitely check out taylor's of
tech's channel right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
you